selena gomez hostess with mimosas
tonight are you nervous
do you feel excited how cool is it to be
out in the world again
i have to be honest i was a little
nervous i
i love being a part of you know
especially moments like this
but we haven't done any of this in a
long time so i'm actually
really nervous but why i'm here and in
general
is that i've i've been using my platform
for the past
year year and a half to confront issues
with
heads of businesses philanthropists
people who may not be giving the proper
information to people
and i think the whole goal of this event
is to show people what the world could
be like and give you facts
of what this vaccination is and i think
that encouraging other people to maybe
look
into it and not get their information
maybe at a false source
so i'm just excited and i hope people
have a chance to see the other side
well i love this and then there's
nothing like getting like the most
star-studded group of people together
ben affleck jennifer lopez harry and
megan
i mean i know it's pretty great how cool
is that to be around everyone it feels
like this is the best award show of the
year
well i will say that to me it's the best
award show of the year because i'm
hosting
no i i was equally geeked out when i
found out who was going to be here and i
was happy that these people
decided to to join us and spread the
word
everyone watching tonight what do you
hope everyone takes home from
watching tonight i hope they feel a
sense of comfortability
safeness hopefully more educated
about what's going on and my dream would
be for everyone to get vaccinated
i love that thank you very much